The internet has been around
for longer than the web.
While computers
already had something
to communicate with over the
internet, like email or FTP,
there was no common
and publicly available
way to publish and
access documents.
This is where Tim
Berners-Lee comes in.
He wanted an open
mechanism for researchers
to publish, read, and comment
on papers through the internet.
He wanted a mesh of
linked documents that were
called hypertext documents.
Berners-Lee chose
a subset of SGML
and called it HTML, the
Hypertext Markup Language.
Then he designed HTTP, the
Hypertext Transfer Protocol,
to transfer these
HTML documents.
Hypertext sounds all
futuristic and complicated.
But it simply means that
the text in that document
can have references
to other documents.
These references
are called links.
By getting a document, the user
can not only read that document
but they can navigate to related
documents through these links.
Especially in a
scientific context
for which Berners-Lee
designed it,
this feature turned out
to be incredibly useful.
Hypertext can refer to
more than text, though.
Files can link to images,
code, styles, or anything else.